The most basic parabola has the equation y equal x squared. Now, we can tell
that the center, or really the vertex of this parabola is at the origin, 0
comma 0. The parabola opens in the upward direction, and it has an a value of
1. The a value is simply the number that's in front of the x squared term.
Since it's not listed, we know that the coefficient is a 1. Another interesting
part about parabolas is that they're symmetric. If there's a point on the left
hand side of the graph, then there's another point equally distant away from
its axis of symmetry on the right hand side of the graph. For example, we have
the point negative 3, 9. Then, on the other side of the graph, we have the
point 3 comma 9. We also have the point negative 2, 4. And on the right side of
the graph, we also have the point 2 comma 4. Two units in the horizontal
direction right, and then four units vertically up. The lowest point, or the
turning point for our parabola, is the vertex. It's at the origin, 0 comma 0.
Now we could make an x and y table and create a table of values to get our
graph. But an easier way to get a couple points on the graph is to look at the
a value. We're going to zoom in on this parabola. We can find the basic shape
of this parabola by looking at the a value. The points to the left and to the
right of the vertex will be exactly 1 unit above the current point. So we move
one unit left, and one unit up. We move one unit up since the a value is one.
And then to get the symmetric point, we move in the opposite direction. One
unit right, and one unit up. So, we can see that we have a point of negative 1
comma 1, and a point of 1 comma 1. Let's make another graph and see some
comparisons. For the graph y equals 2x squared, we also get a parabola. This
parabolas vertex is at the origin, its still 0 0. But what's different the a
value. Now the a value is 2. So to get the basic shape of this graph, we'll
move 1 unit 3 and 1 unit left from the vertex. Then we'll go a units up in this
case 2 units. So 1 unit left and 2 units up. This gives us our first point at
negative 1, 2. Then we can move 1 unit right. And 2 units up to give ourselves
another at 1, 2 and here is a 3rd parabola y equals 3x squared. Notice that the
turning point of the vertex where this parabola is still at 0,0, the origin. To
find other points on this purple parabola we're going to use our a value. We
can move 1 unit left and 3 units up. This gives us coordinate of negative 1, 3.
To find another point on the graph, we'll go the opposite way. We'll go 1 unit
right, and this time 3 units up. This gives us a point of 1 comma 3. The a
value is always a quick way to get 1 point that is to the left of the vertex.
And 1 point that is to the right of the vertex whenever parabola is in the form
of y equals. Notice 2 that as the a value gets bigger our parabola stretches
vertically or in other words it gets more narrow.